il était déjà entré dans la légende de
son vivant il ya tout juste 30 ans
disparaissait jimi hendrix on mesure
mieux aujourd'hui son influence même si
la carrière du guitariste a été très
courte
en france ses plus grands admirateurs
n'ont rien oublié portrait de l'un
d'entre eux signé michel vial et
alexandre dupont
jimi hendrix et yazid manou rien de ce
qui concerne le premier ne laisse
indifférent le second entre la première
rock star noire et le jeune adolescent
des années 70 un courant mystérieux et
passer instantanément provoquant l'une
de ces histoires de fascination
admiration qui défie toute analyse de
regarder une froide sur la télé d'albert
raisner points chauds ils ont présenté
un guitariste comme étant tous quand
guitariste rock du monde et en même
temps qu'il lui présentait le type était
mort
très envie plus commencé en savoir sur
le type donc branché indien la drogue
les femmes la musique l'accoutrement les
bandeaux gj tombé dedans de la fin de
son enfance jusqu'à son entrée dans le
monde adulte le jeune homme se contente
d'être un simple fan jusqu'à cette idée
folle en 1990 de monter en hommage à son
idole à l'olympia pour les 20 ans de sa
mort avec son seul enthousiasme et sa
seule énergie
il réussit son projet et entre du coup
dans la vie professionnelle
ouais
hendricks a complètement changé ma vie
enfin à partir de 90 puisque avant une
spa syrien à partir de ce moment là où
je suis devenu attaché de presse
toujours lui en tant que fils prend du
temps parce que depuis ces dix ans je me
suis pas occupée que d'hendrix il a
toujours été là mais hendrix et pas que
l'expérience ni ressources et
l'expérience mais d'autres ont dit ah
non moi ce que j'aime en rixe c'est la
fin cedeno jiechi
ce qu'il y à entre jimmy hendrix et
yazid manou le second né cinq ans avant
la mort du premier est bien en peine de
l'expliquer mais il ne perd pas une
occasion de le faire mieux connaître
reste ces liens indéfinissable et
irrationnel qui peuvent exister enfin
l'artiste et son public les liens assez
forts pour transformer une passion en
métier